you
hi this video is for anyone interested
in syntax especially anyone who is still
interested in syntax after going through
my introduction to the grammar of
sentences series I'd like to present a
short overview of computational grammars
and generative syntax I'll spend some
time exploring what simple sentences
tell us about human language grammar
I'll take a look at the now classic
parse tree or x-bar model that attempts
to capture what humans are doing when we
speak a language and put sentences
together and I'll conclude by mentioning
a few other models of human grammar the
terms language and grammar get thrown
around a lot and it would take me well
beyond my time here to work out a sturdy
definition with you I'll merely point
you in a single direction narrowing
language down to natural human language
which is an umbrella term for the
specific first language you learned as a
child your first language and whatever
system or process you had available to
you as a child that allowed you to learn
that language at this point the notion
of grammar becomes relevant under one
approach the grammar is something you
have in your mind that gets configured
in a certain way allowing you to use a
language under another approach a
grammar is something you puzzle out of a
language as you learn it in either case
notice that grammar is not a set of
literary stylistic or social preferences
like don't say a taint ain't a word
instead the linguistic understanding of
grammar seeks out the fundamental
mechanism for sentence production the
common way to conceive of this grammar
of natural language is to ground it in
the speech of real speakers and to
explain it as a series of rules let's
clarify rule here these rules are
statements or imperatives that tell the
system how to handle chunks of language
the grammar using our linguistic
definition of that term takes some input
processes processes that input using a
series of rules statements and produces
or generates some output this setup
means that grammar allows certain
sentences and disallows others its
ability to generate language earns this
broad stroke model of grammar the title
generative grammar one tool for modeling
linguistic grammar is x-bar theory this
model parses the grammar of sentences by
looking for the relationships between
word classes
determining how to group these words
into phrases working out the key word or
head word of the phrase and building
back until we can view the grammar of a
whole sentence as a single expanded tree
here's a simple tree for the sentence
the boss ate soup
the major nodes on this tree are phrases
each phrase has a head for example the
head of a verb phrases a verb the other
elements in a phrase are either
specifiers or complements specifiers are
sisters of the sub phrases within a
phrase meaning that they branch off from
the main phrase here and sit parallel
with any sub phrase below the main
phrase comments complements our sisters
of the head so they branch out next to
the head word like happy and from Rome
if we added happy boss from Rome the
specifier still stays up here on the
branch the first branch of the noun
phrase specifiers and complements our
relative and found throughout the tree
just like heads the subject of the
sentence this noun phrase here is the
specifier of this sentence note together
the head and the specifiers and
complements make up all the material in
a phrase the tree still relies on terms
for word classes which traditional
grammarians call parts of speech like
noun verb preposition or determiner what
if I want to add a prepositional phrase
like at home to the sentence well we
have to expand the nodes in our verb
phrase instead of just the node down
here for the verb and the noun phrase
over here we need a prepositional phrase
but this structure verb noun phrase
prepositional phrase starts to flatten
out our tree when we start asserting the
syntactic structure of a language of a
chunk of language like this it makes
sense to figure out if the arrangements
were choosing have linguistic support do
we have any reason to maintain this flat
structure or on the contrary do we have
any rationale for adding some depth to
this verb phrase consider two pieces of
natural language data as evidence the
boss ate soup at home the boss ate at
home soup the second sentence doesn't
work because the prepositional phrase
material falls too close to the verb it
seems like that the verb expects the
core argument soup to
follow core arguments seemed to fall
adjacent to the verb for more about core
arguments see my video on the verb and
its arguments I'll leave a link below
before we solve this flatten this
problem in our our tree let me just take
a quick sidetrack into the issue of
linguistic evidence
ideally any grammar we're proposing
especially any grammar that we claim
models how humans produce language or at
least how computers can produce human
language must account for the kinds of
sentences it models evidence includes
sentences that impact the claim that our
grammar works and this evidence can be
positive because it's a well-formed
natural language sentence or negative
because a speaker of a natural language
would judge it as unfit negative
evidence like the sentence the boss ate
soup at home is marked with an asterisk
by convention back to our tree let's
account for the ordering of verb noun
phrase prepositional phrase by
prioritizing their distance from the
head verb ate we add some intermediate
nodes below the V the verb sum V Bar
nodes that allow us to expand adjacent
phrases now we can see that the noun
phrase sits closer to the verb and the
prepositional phrase appears at a
distance from the verb we've modeled a
complete sentence now let's pull back
and make some general observations then
works through some useful terminology
for moving around this tree first notice
that we have multiple kinds of phrases
noun phrase for prepositional phrase
verb phrase but they all behave in the
same way containing some head noun verb
or preposition and expanding out either
to the left or the right we can abstract
this concept and say that all of our
phrases take the form X phrase where X
stands for some head word class since
the X phrase expands to some node X bar
the whole model takes name x-bar theory
what about our top node s well there's a
mismatch between all of our expanding X
phrase nodes here which have the form of
some X and P and this top branching node
which isn't named some X phrase think of
a more appropriate name like
inflectional phrase of course it follows
that the head of this inflectional
phrase is some
I the inflection may be pulled out as
tense and agreement information because
it's a finite sentence we can even
expand beyond this individual sentence
here to a CP complementizer phrase was
somewhere that that connects it to even
larger chunks of language at this point
we we made a parse tree that we can walk
starting at the top node this node
dominates all the nodes below it the
nodes below each dominate the nodes
below them in all cases notice that each
node in our tree dominates at most two
other nodes we've followed the binary
branching hypothesis which maintains
this kind of structure to give our
sentences depth flexibility and
according to proponents grammatical
accuracy nodes falling to the left of
other nodes on the same level proceed
nodes to the right this precedence
differs from dominance nodes immediately
dominated by a node C command every node
dominated by that immediate dominating
node so here V Bar C commands
prepositional phrase we continue walking
all of these branches of this tree to
all of these branching nodes until we
get down to the bottom nodes the
terminal symbols which contain the
actual words and morphemes of the
sentence there's a shorthand way to
capture this whole grammar in a
collection of statements called rewrite
rules we've seen that a noun phrase
dominates an N bar and an N that a verb
phrase expands to V bar and V or another
phrase like a noun phrase or
prepositional phrase so we can take all
these together and say that an X phrase
where X is your head word can be
re-written as some Y phrase some other
phrase or an X bar then an X bar can be
re-written as an X or a wife phrase and
that in any X once you get to an X
you're at it you've arrived at a
terminal symbol this takes us from the
top to the bottom of the tree parse
trees may help computers and people
resolve the kinds of ambiguities that
thrive in natural language you're
already aware that sentences can be
ambiguous somebody has certainly told
you something that could be
interpreted in different ways ambiguity
has two general scopes a sentence can
have global ambiguity or local ambiguity
global ambiguity impacts the whole
sentence as in the canonical example
time flies like an arrow local ambiguity
is limited to one or more pieces of a
sentence
besides scope there are also different
types of ambiguity structural ambiguity
occurs when more than one parse tree can
be used to represent the sentence so
different grammatical structures are
yielding different interpretations of
the sentence consider again the sentence
time flies like an arrow if you haven't
evaluated that phrase before think about
it now you can understand the sentence
in multiple ways including with time as
the verb flies as the verb or like as
the verb when one of the leaves of a
parse tree the words can be understood
in multiple ways you have an example of
word sense ambiguity the meaning of the
word cards in she has cards in her
pocket is ambiguous we know it's a noun
but does it mean credit cards or playing
cards when it's unclear what a pronoun
refers back to that's the case of
referential ambiguity in John told Jake
that he has to come to the party we know
that he is a pronoun but does it refer
to John or to Jake all right it's time
to conclude this rough survey of parse
trees the topic of grammars is deep
contentious and central to questions
about the structure of individual
languages the human brains ability to
acquire language computer processing of
language and artificial intelligence
there are many linguistic models of
grammar including other rule based
approaches statistical approach is based
on large amounts of natural language
data and approaches that see language as
the outcome of competing ranked viable
constraints instead of inviolable rules
but those are all topics for another day
it's been fun to work through a
simplified model with you and thanks for
learning with me